Use the quadratic formula to
solve the equation, 0 is equal
to negative 7q squared
plus 2q plus 9.
Now, the quadratic formula, it
applies to any quadratic
equation of the form--
we could put the 0 on
the left hand side.
0 is equal to ax squared
plus bx plus c.
And we generally deal with x's,
in this problem we're
dealing with q's.
But the quadratic formula says,
look, if you have a
quadratic equation of this form,
that the solutions of
this equation are going to be
x is going to be equal to
negative b plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus
4ac-- all of that over 2a.
And this is actually two
solutions here, because
there's one solution where you
take the positive square root
and there's another solution
where you take
the negative root.
So it gives you both
roots of this.
So if we look at the quadratic
equation that we need to solve
here, we can just
pattern match.
We're dealing with q's, not
x's, but this is the same
general idea.
It could be x's if you like.
And if we look at it, negative
7 corresponds to a.
That is our a.
It's the coefficient on the
second degree term.
2 corresponds to b.
It is the coefficient on
the first degree term.
And then 9 corresponds to c.
It's the constant.
So, let's just apply the
quadratic formula.
The quadratic formula will tell
us that the solutions--
the q's that satisfy this
equation-- q will be equal to
negative b.
b is 2.
Plus or minus the square root
of b squared, of 2 squared,
minus 4 times a times negative
7 times c, which is 9.
And all of that over 2a.
All of that over 2 times
a, which is once
again negative 7.
And then we just have
to evaluate this.
So this is going to be equal
to negative 2 plus or minus
the square root of-- let's see,
2 squared is 4-- and then
if we just take this part right
here, if we just take
the negative 4 times negative
7 times 9, this negative and
that negative is going
to cancel out.
So it's just going to become
a positive number.
And 4 times 7 times 9.
4 times 9 is 36.
36 times 7.
Let's do it up here.
7 times 6 is 42.
7 times 3, or 3 times 7 is 21.
Plus 4 is 25.
252.
So this becomes 4 plus 252.
Remember, you have a
negative 7 and you
have a minus out front.
Those cancel out, that's why
we have a positive 252 for
that part right there.
And then our denominator,
2 times negative
7 is negative 14.
Now what does this equal?
Well, we have this is equal to
negative 2 plus or minus the
square root of-- what's
4 plus 252?
It's just 256.
All of that over negative 14.
And what's 256?
What's the square root of 256?
It's 16.
You can try it out
for yourself.
This is 16 times 16.
So the square root
of 256 is 16.
So we can rewrite this whole
thing as being equal to
negative 2 plus 16
over negative 14.
Or negative 2 minus-- right?
This is plus 16 over
negative 14.
Or minus 16 over negative 14.
If you think of it as plus or
minus, that plus is that plus
right there.
And if you have that minus,
that minus is
that minus right there.
Now we just have to evaluate
these two numbers.
Negative 2 plus 16 is 14 divided
by negative 14 is
negative 1.
So q could be equal
to negative 1.
Or negative 2 minus 16 is
negative 18 divided by
negative 14 is equal
to 18 over 14.
The negatives cancel out, which
is equal to 9 over 7.
So q could be equal to negative
1, or it could be
equal to 9 over 7.
And you could try these out,
substitute these q's back into
this original equation, and
verify for yourself that they
satisfy it.
We could even do it with
the first one.
So if you take q is equal
to negative 1.
Negative 7 times negative 1
squared-- negative 1 squared
is just 1-- so this would be
negative 7 times 1, right?
That's negative 1 squared.
Negative 1 times 2 is
minus 2 plus 9.
So it's negative 7 minus 2,
which is negative 9, plus 9,
does indeed equal 0.
So this checks out.
And I'll leave it up to you
to verify that 9 over
7 also works out.